does MAF Gideon finally get defeated
will grogu at long last be promoted to
Mandalorian apprentice and what can we
expect for season four you've got
questions about the season 3 ending of
the Mandalorian we've got answers for
most of the Mandalorian season 3 the end
game is clear finally after multiple
seasons and Decades of in-universe
Oppression under the Empire the
mandalorians are ready to retake their
home at the beginning of the show din
shows little interest in the idea of
restoring Mandalore but that's fitting
for the show while DIN and grogu are
still Central Boca tan has gradually
become a co-star along with them by
throwing her into the spotlight season 3
brings in storylines that have been
running since the Clone Wars this
history makes the season finale all the
more impactful thanks to a combined
force of Boca Tan's old mercenaries the
children of the watch and a few
mandalorians who are abandoned on
Mandalore moff Gideon Falls his army of
Stormtroopers cosplaying as mandalorians
is defeated as are his Elite praetorian
guards amid the destruction of his base
the finale offers hope for a bright
future on Mandalore the world's once
Lush landscape is glimpsed in
underground cave Gardens at long last
the Clans are united in a glorious
mission to heal not to conquer for Bo
Katan rebuilding a society that's been
devastated by eons of war is definitely
not going to be easy but it truly feels
like the mandalorians can do it this
time they can forge a new future for
themselves and their descendants
moff Gideon's delusional self-importance
has stood in opposition to the
Mandalorian people since season one he's
the ultimate colonialist a man so
infatuated with the idea of Empire that
he dresses up in a store-bought Darth
Vader Halloween costume to make himself
feel tall we have known since season one
that Mandalore was a pet project for
Gideon we know that he fancies himself a
superior version of the Mandalorian
warrior even though his only maxed out
skills are monologuing and zoom calls by
the end of the Mandalorian season 3
Gideon's delusions of grandeur catch up
to him but not before he makes an
absolute fool of himself
mandalorians are weak once they lose
their trinkets creating an army of
force-sensitive super soldiers equipped
with Mandalorian Weaponry not a bad plan
but when you use yourself a middle-aged
middle manager in Gideon's case as the
template it starts to fall apart where
Palpatine represents the power-hungry
evil of Empire and Vader represents
those it corrupts Gideon represents the
sad desperate Rubes who sell their souls
for a lie of significance in short
Gideon embodies the myth that Colonial
Empire sells to its agents that you are
both capable and deserving of becoming
an emperor unto yourself if you stand on
the shoulders of someone else's culture
so it's apt then that Gideon's world
comes crashing down on him manifested in
the form of a flaming Imperial light
Cruiser the mandalorians are stronger
than Gideon and his Stormtroopers
they're more skilled better trained and
more dedicated these facts have never
been in doubt but they also haven't led
to many wins in the past the Empire has
numbers money and best car bocatan leads
her United Mandalorian front to victory
at the end of season 3 and it's that
Unity that's the key all the skill and
knee rockets in the world won't Prevail
if infighting persists at least that's
the message that the Mandalorian tries
to drive home Beau says it herself while
facing off against Gideon
mandalorians are stronger together this
isn't just a commentary on their past
division in the show but across all of
the Star Wars Canon Dave filoni's modern
Mandalorian Saga began in January of
2010 with the Clone Wars episode The
Mandalore plot if you've been following
the story since then it's been a long
journey Civil Wars led to a peaceful
government which was dismantled by
terrorist attacks and political
corruption the planet was taken over by
crime syndicates and renegades Sith then
thrown under the Fist of the empire for
so long the mandalorians have battled
one another and suffered the
consequences but in the Mandalorian
season 3 finale it's their cooperation
and shared Vision that ultimately leads
them to Victory even in the Final Duel
against moff Gideon himself it takes the
combined efforts of bocatan din and
grogu to finish him off that's not a
mark of Gideon's Superior power but
rather a mark of just how strong Unity
can be
since Star Wars the Clone Wars the
darksaber has been at the center of the
Mandalorian story only a successful
fight to the death can earn someone the
ancient weapon and only its power can
unite the Clans According to some in
reality the Black Blade has been more of
a curse since it was introduced in the
Clone Wars Darth Maul uses it to kill
Duchess sateen Crees MAF Gideon uses it
to oppress the Mandalorian people and
bocatan's lack of claim to the sword
erodes her reputation with her followers
so maybe it's for the best and a little
bit fitting that the darksaber is
destroyed in the climactic battle with
Gideon perhaps as bocatan has repeatedly
suggested rules that Force mandalorians
to kill each other aren't rules worth
following perhaps the darksaber didn't
represent the strength of Mandalore but
the weakness of its people's unending
desire for Bloodshed by destroying the
weapon Gideon may have actually set the
mandalorians free it's a new era now one
where the possession of an ancient Relic
won't determine who's fit to rule
watching rogu learn more about himself
and the galaxy has always been a high
point of the Mandalorian he demonstrates
just how far he's come in the final
battle on Mandalore in which he saves
din from Stormtroopers fends off three
praetorian guards helps bocatan defeat
moff Gideon and protects the whole Squad
from a massive explosion his Force
Shield technique is particularly
striking because it echoes the end of
the Mandalorian season 1. back then it
took all of grogu's might just to stop a
single flame Trooper now he can hold
back the fires of a crashing star
Cruiser it's only fitting Then That
season 3 ends with grogu promoted from
foundling to Mandalorian Apprentice
grogu is my Apprentice
he is no longer a foundling
add him to the
and with that advancement in rank comes
an even more important development being
officially adopted by DIN jarin and
taking on the name din grogu it's sweet
satisfying and bound to give you a lump
in the throat at the end of the
Mandalorian season 3 finale din tells
New Republic Ranger Carson Teva that he
wants a more reputable line of work now
that he's a father he proposes working
as a freelance contractor for the new
Republic which would definitely be a
step up from ordinary bounty hunting
with this new job under his belt and a
cute little house to raise groguin din
has really come full circle we first
meet him in season one running dangerous
missions on Navarro the planet is a
wretched Hive of scum villainy and
Imperial holdouts and the mandalorians
live in the sewers now at the end of
season 3 Dennis living on the same
Planet but things are quite different
his work has helped transform Navarro
into a thriving trade Hub and he has an
official sanction from the galactic
government to suss out and put away bad
guys if there is one prevailing theme in
the Mandalorian season 3 it's summed up
Midway through the finale the captain of
the survivors who've been living on
Mandalore leads bocatan and her crew to
a safe haven a cave teeming with
Wildlife he tells Beau that they have
been planting Farms to restore the
ecosystem and when she asks how such a
thing is possible on a Barren Planet he
responds that life persists the
sentiment worked in Jurassic Park and it
works here too no matter how powerful
evil may become the Natural Balance of
the universe will always find a way to
fight back this theme underscores most
of the season bocatan is alone and
hopeless at the start after losing the
dark saber and her forces but by
reconnecting with her Heritage she finds
New Hope Navarro manages to become a
peaceful world despite Decades of outer
rim chaos and Imperial violence
the first two seasons of the Mandalorian
Focus squarely on din's adventures most
of the action takes place in the outer
rim or the mid rim and a handful of New
Republic Rangers are the only glimpse of
core Galactic Society all that changes
in season three we get an entire episode
on Coruscant numerous deep dives into
the nature of post-imperial politics and
a look behind the curtain at Grand
Admiral thrawn's impending return one
message prevails through all of this the
new Republic isn't half as safe or
secure as it would like to think the
amnesty program meant to rehabilitate
former Imperials is full of holes
allowing for people like Elia Kane to
gain New Republic access while still
working for the Empire the outer rim is
far too large for the government to
police or protect and the so-called
Shadow Council remains active in well
the Shadows all of this helps explain
the rise of the first order in the
sequel Trilogy it might have seemed
strange and even rushed in the force
awakens when the first order appeared on
the scene and quickly destroyed half a
dozen planets but now we see just how
much care careful scheming and New
Republic in efficacy led to that moment
well the new Republic's struggles and
the Imperial Remnant schemes the rest of
the Galaxy seems to be thriving the
Mandalorian season 3 seems to argue that
Grassroots Community projects not
massive governments are the way forward
especially in the outer rim and the mid
Rim Navarro is the best example of this
turning saloons into schoolhouses and
dangerous environments into hospitable
homes and often overlooked aspect of the
Star Wars story is that the Republic
truly was corrupt by the time Palpatine
toppled it the Senate failed to serve
its constituents the galactic Corps
hoarded The Riches of the Galaxy and
there was rampant corruption these ideas
are alluded to in the prequels but
they're even clearer in the Clone Wars
the Mandalorian season 3 suggests that
the new Republic isn't really much
better the Galaxy is certainly improving
now that it's out from under Palpatine's
thumb but it's the regular people
fighting for their own localities not
the bigwigs on Coruscant who make the
difference as the old Mandalorian
Captain says if the plants on Mandalore
all they need to thrive is room to grow
after retaking Mandalore defeating moff
Gideon and officially becoming a family
DIN and grogu have earned some time off
at their new home on Navarro but the
Mandalorian season 4 is coming and we
already have some Clues as to what it
might hold Gideon may be gone but the
Imperial Remnant is still building
strength in the far reaches of space
Grand Admiral thrawn is set to return in
Ahsoka and his campaign against the New
Republic could spill into season four
now that din is a contractor for the
galactic government he could be called
into action against thrawn and since
Dave filoni is now making a Star Wars
movie to wrap up the so-called mandover
Saga it's likely that the shows will
continue to overlap in big ways as for
Mandalore itself things look bright the
armorer Tells Dan at the end of season 3
that he must take rogu on adventures now
that he's his Apprentice which will
likely keep the pair away from the
Homeworld for a while a fresh run of
episodic voyages likely awaits in season
4 but will probably still get some
visits to bocatan's reconstruction
efforts the bigger question now isn't
what the Mandalorian season 4 will hold
but when it will arrive
foreign